Hãy nhớ súng hành ngày, điều đã tất sự át quả trưa ra.
Cần nữa là bật dục quyền tổ trong gì đâu cả nhân,
cấp chỉ biết nhau người để là bật bất lý tân trong cuộc sống hành ngày.
Tìm vầy không phải loại con nào cũng đã tư trở bị kẻ át quả trưa ra.
Cậm dứt tổ cấp kinh đe sổ tảm đe sổ răng tư trở, sau không không không không không vui không chết là quả.
Không rời kích tưởng không một buồn và không chết đe trắng.
Chết sẽ mềm sai đành không rất một buồn, đe sử dục khi phải xí dạ tài mặt ra vẻ.
Cái cấp dây lần môi bố nhìn mấy cảm xem đi mẹt tổng tích kìm.
Lọc bề hấp nằm để bệnh chung đình.
Cái cấp dốc bề hát tự tuyên của ra.
Sẵn tầm bồn nắp bật tệ lời sẽ bảo quả của hợp túng trong gia đình.
Thì đi ra, ra ngoại con xấu tý tuyên nhà bệ sinh.
Hẹn sẵn tầm đăng có con bố tùm mấy hành hồi,
khăn rứt cao các tệ lời trọc cá ra đình.
Hân chần, bùi tìm, bùi này tạc đấy.